hey guys Ryan right here pretty fast
here so we're gonna check out the second
trailer today for Jurassic Park world
Jurassic world I mean second trailer for
it the official second trailer I love
the first trailer I saw the one clip
they released wasn't that impressive
wasn't their chemistry just wasn't that
good
the acting wasn't that whatever it's the
chemistry more I think but [ __ ] it I'm
still jacked to see it I get too excited
for things it's not about control
standing it's a relationship based on
respect
these animals are thinking I gotta eat
your hood Wow
I got you gotta be able to relate to at
least one of those things
every time we've unveiled a new
attraction potaters respite
corporate felt genetic classification
without the wow factor they're dinosaurs
Wow enough she was designed to be bigger
than the t-rex what happened to the
sibling she ate it
we have an asset out of containment
what is that they're tracking implants
he plotted out how would it know to do
that
she remembered when they cleared it
she's killing for sport
20,000 people you got no more votes you
don't have enough guns
if we do this we do this my way yeah
your eyes are Tory lighting it up
something's wrong they're communicating
about an animal here
highly intelligent animal
doesn't look so much no hey looks
intense
that looks really intense I kind of feel
like the trailer we gave away a lot it
did I would have liked some of that to
be a nice surprise
you know like hearing that the dinosaurs
are like communicating with each other
and sort of like teaming up to take you
what they did that in the first one so
it's not that big of a surprise we
wouldn't know see that Brandi did the
velociraptors do the velociraptors yeah
because they're a pack but I'm talking
about like it's their same like all the
dinosaurs are like kind of coming
together you know before it's like these
dinosaurs are with each other these
dinosaurs are with each other and then
they just attack I think that's what
they're implying
yeah they're all a team and they're
learning to communicate stay but if
they're a team why are they killing each
other for sport ah that's the one crazy
dinosaur [ __ ] the dinosaur does look
scary maybe oh you know what I think is
gonna happen cuz he's friends kind of
with the velociraptors so the
velociraptors are gonna help him get the
other dinosaur because it's a vigilante
why do you think that's gonna happen
that is pretty clear that that's what's
gonna happen the trailer literally laid
it out for us
oh yeah he said we're gonna do it my way
and then he's on the motorcycle a bunch
of the records but it could have been
like they're following or chasing him it
could probably think so Jurassic Park
had a good mixture of animatronics and
CGI well I get that groundbreaking CGI
at the time it's still pretty good this
looks like it's all CGI which is a
little bit of a letdown to me cuz I like
the animatronics they look what it looks
scary you look very real because it was
animatronic so that's terrifying
and I missed that because everything
here looks CGI and that kind of pulls me
out a little bit okay but besides that
it still looks really good as long as
the actors are really believing what's
going on I'm gonna believe what's going
on yeah you know it's like if if I'm not
aware that they're acting off a green
screen right now no then I won't be
bothered I thought it was good
and they intercut the dinosaurs with
their conversation with before and it
really added a nice element to it so I
hope they do that in the movie as well
because the clip that they released
before with them talking with Bryce
Dallas Howard and Chris Pratt yeah it
was just kind of boring but when they
enter cut it with other stuff it looked
really interesting yeah I look like the
Jam is a lot better than what we saw
yeah this looks like the most
action-packed Jurassic Park unless they
put all this stuff in the trailer maybe
because the other Jurassic park's I
wouldn't consider them action movies
that like every danger happens horror
happens and it's thrilling it's
suspenseful this looks like there's like
a lot of action sequences I like the
transportation in it there kind of other
little space bubble here little space
Bonnie yeah those are cool I love how
they think that's safe yeah I'm like
these are giant monsters and you're like
my little plastic bubble is gonna
protect me these guys I do like that
homage to jury trial Jurassic Park when
that when they're in the bubble and then
the dinosaur breaks through from the top
of the glass yeah yeah that was cool
that was cool
this director seems like he knows how to
amplify that's what I like about it it
doesn't look like he's trying make
Jurassic Park it looks like he's trying
to take it to the next level you know
like if this feels like an action movie
I don't know if it'll work as well but
if he feels like a suspenseful thriller
again that has action sequences that's
when it'll really work but if it's just
like an action thrill ride I'm sure I'll
still be fun and entertaining but I
won't be as like stoked about yeah I
won't be as stoked about it other than
that I mean I'm definitely gonna be
there like opening night not like
without a doubt it's look it's well
we've been hearing about a part for four
years I know anyway guys thanks for
mentioning that was out if you're new to
the chanela you can subscribe to the
real rejects randy has a channel too it
covers a lot of indie news check that
out
those trailer reactions too and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
because we're social media junkies oh I
forgot there's a rating system now yeah
I keep forgetting about the rating
system is it it's either definitely
going to the theaters variations of that
okay wait for it on DVD variations of
that like now
likes Amazon whatever and not even
bother with it I will definitely be
going on IMAX screenshots on so we just
read this message from a shout out
person got a share with you warning it
gets dark halfway through
hey bro my name's Logan I'm 18 years old
I just wanted to let you know I'm a
massive fan of the channel shoutouts to
you down here in New Zealand it's always
been a great to fire up a Billy she
thinks that's a goat I think that's a
joint and watch your vids you bring a
lot of entertainment to the day and I
would like to say a big thanks to you if
I could get a shout out it would mean a
lot to me here we go as I just found out
earlier this week that my girlfriend of
two years has been [ __ ] another dude
for the past few months I have been
pretty down the past week and a
shout-out would really help uplift my
spirits and bring some happiness to me
during this really shitty part of my
life anyway cheers for the banter and I
wish you all the success you deserve
Thank You Logan throughout the whole
message all I got was how awesome the
real rejects are that's what you would
get that's what I really got from that
mess yeah he's pretty egocentric yeah
everything else Connor doesn't matter to
me
I'm kidding I'm kidding listen man Logan
if you already broke up with her good
stay broken up with her don't get back
with her no um if you are with her break
up with that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] right
now can you do another life cool stream
of curse words [ __ ] Horicon [ __ ]
[ __ ] dick loving mother [ __ ] [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] mongers yeah and listen I
had this idea that I was sharing with
Brandi of what you should do to get
revenge if you have Nikki photos don't
post it on social networks don't do it
do it don't do it well look look ya'll
here's what I've learned over the years
you won't get sued you won't possibly
face jail time you'll be fine it really
nothing did bad can come from that
too bad nothing bad she sent you those
you have whatever you want to do with
those no that does not that's a courtesy
if you're far away from one another and
the other thing to that guy kick his ass
kick his ass
take photos after kicking his ass post
them on social networks too you'll never
get in trouble not even a little bit
yeah and if you believe that you're not
very smart Logan I have faith in you get
your revenge mr. Clarke move on with
your life
[ __ ] only way to get closures get
revenge
does anything movies have taught me it's
kid revision she'd be a good bird yeah
yeah yeah